joining me now ari fleischer former
white house press secretary fox news
contributor author of the new book
suppression deception snobbery and bias
why the press gets so much wrong and
molly hemingway editor-in-chief of the
federalist and fox news contributor
ari i'm seeing this and i know you are
as well there's
an unmistakable shift
in the media's tone here they they see
the iceberg
and it's the midterm elections and it
seems like they're bearing down on that
iceberg pretty fast
yeah and the danger here for joe biden
and all democrats in the house and in
the senate and why a lot of districts
that you thought were going to be safe
democrat are going to be in play this
november is all this is a sign of how
depressed the democratic base is now
what happens laura in these first
midterm elections the opposite party is
excited they ginned up they can't wait
to go vote the bums out of office and
that's the way a lot of people feel
about joe biden but the democrat base is
not excited they were never really
excited by joe biden to begin with they
just saw him as the alternative to
donald trump and now that he's doing so
poorly
and you have liberal columnists piling
on it further demoralizes depresses the
democratic base leading to a november
election which republicans surge in
turnout and democrats stay home
that compounds all of the democrat
problems that's why it's likely to be a
tsunami in november
well i think molly they're also getting
nastier as things are getting more
desperate for the democrats
something that nicole wallace said
watch
i worry that in covering glenn juncken
and his politics of parental choice all
the focus was on how well it worked and
even in our conversations about desantis
it's about how well they're serving him
the the truth is
dehumanization
as a tactic for politics is from war the
russians get their soldiers
to rape children by dehumanizing them
it's being deployed in our politics
molly your reaction to that that
unhinged rant
it is unhinged and it's really it's
something she should actually apologize
for this is the type of rhetoric that is
really unacceptable
but it is an indication again of what
we're seeing in this election at this
time because of how much the democrat
party has kind of moved precipitously to
the left and become much more abnormal
in its politics it's allowing
republicans to take this massive amount
of ground to sort of that 80 percent of
the country that's normal that doesn't
think that people should talk to kids
about sex or gender issues without
parental consent and turning that into a
political issue when it's really broadly
supported by you know members of
by voters in both parties really gets it
to at what ari was just saying about the
trouble that democrats are going to have
come november
and ari there was a news of a potential
bernie 2024 run today so this exchange
from his former staffer was interesting
i was critical of governor desantis
still am uh during um the height of
covid but if you really look at the
numbers florida actually
came out got a story to tell you all
right he has a story the economy is
strong and the economy is strong
i mean i almost fell out of my chair
there ari it's almost as if they're
finally getting it desantis actually
managed the situation pretty well
she needs to be careful she's either
going to get herself canceled or joe
biden's bunny rabbit's going to attack
her
look
one of the big factors going on in all
these elections in all these states is
the republicans in red states have been
talking common sense and it started when
coveted began republicans were much more
in tune with the needs of the people and
there's also a looking back on how
successful things were under president
trump how strong the economy was a child
poverty had dropped how unemployment was
so low for blacks for hispanics how we
were at peace across the country the
destruction of isis
all those successes shutting down the
border also all those successes have
just been washed away by joe biden
reversing everything he could possibly
do regardless of the consequences and
now you're starting to hear at least
some people frankly acknowledge how well
republican governors have done you know
republicans have a great big deep bench
and we're seeing examples of that every
day
molly
it seems to me that
from new england to the southwest
to the midwest
something's changing i mean you feel it
you feel it in the hispanic polling you
feel it in the polling of young people
they might not have liked some things
about trump and that's that's what they
think but
they know this is bad
they know it no there's no spinning it
spinning it as biden cares or he feels
your pain or he was poor wants to
none of that makes a difference
and again this isn't just a biden
problem but an entire democrat party
problem because they do control
everything in washington dc the
presidency the senate the house you're
seeing in these states where republican
governors are experimenting with
different ways of doing things contrary
to to the way the federal government has
been doing things in recent years that
these are much more popular you saw that
poll just last week showing that biden's
approval numbers are are just horrific
among hispanic voters and what we saw in
2020 yes republicans did poorly in that
election but they had more voters than
they've ever had before and they created
this broad multiracial working-class
party and i think that's got to be very
sobering for democrats going into the
november midterms and into the 2024
election
arie molly great to see both of you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else